good evening ladies and gentlemen I'm
Cheryl Boone Isaacs president of the
Academy and it is my pleasure to welcome
you to the 42nd student Academy Awards
as that wonderful video attests tonight
we are honoring an amazing range of
filmmakers and future Academy members
the student Academy Awards were created
in 1972 as an extension of the Academy's
mission to engage emerging filmmakers
support New Voices and celebrate the
excellent work that is being done by
young filmmakers and tonight it's truly
an international group I'm pleased to
report than in the last few years the
student Academy Awards has come into its
own as one of the world's most exciting
competitions for young filmmakers this
year for the first time submissions were
done online and the number of film
submissions has more than tripled this
year we saw 1686 submissions
representing 282 schools in the US and
many more schools overseas these films
were judged in five categories animation
documentary narrative alternative and
foreign more Academy members than ever
before served as judges this year and
I'd like to thank those members who for
the first time were able to view our
submissions and participate as judges
from as far away as Ireland India China
Italy the UK and Australia your support
of this program as well as other
educational initiatives all serve the
vital purpose of helping us to cultivate
the next generation of filmmakers who
represent the future of our industry and
of our Academy
we could not keep up these wonderful
Academy traditions without your long
hours of dedication
I want to express my heartfelt
congratulations to our student winners
you've joined an elite group of
filmmakers whose ranks include Robert
Zemeckis John Lasseter Pete docter
Trey Parker and Spike Lee along with
many others celebrated filmmakers who
have gone on after winning student
Academy Awards to earn 46 Oscar
nominations and have won or shared eight
Oscars I hope for each of you your
student academy award is the first step
in a very long and successful career I
can speak for all of us at the academy
when I say we can't wait to see what
lies ahead for you now I would like to
introduce our first presenter Michelle
Rodriguez